i'd like to make a statement on the
united kingdom's approach to the global
migration challenge
the united kingdom has a long and proud
history of offering sanctuary to
refugees
in recent years alone we have welcomed
more than 185
000 people through safe and legal routes
including from syria hong kong
afghanistan and more recently ukraine
in addition we have welcomed more than
40 000 people in recent years through
our refugee family reunion routes
this government has done more than any
other in recent history to support those
fleeing persecution conflict or
instability
[Applause]
[Music]
on those who need it most or effectively
control our borders without tackling
illegal migration
which mr speaker is facilitated by
people smugglers serious organized
criminals that profit from human misery
who do not care about people drowning in
the channel or suffocating in the back
of containers
we must break their lethal and evil
business model by removing the demand
for their republican activities
this type of illegal migration puts
sustained unsustainable pressures on our
public services and local communities
every day the broken asylum system costs
the taxpayer almost 5 million pounds in
hotel accommodation loan
the cost of the asylum system is the
highest in over two decades at over 1.5
billion pounds and as the prime minister
mr speaker said last week we cannot
sustain a parallel parallel illegal
system
our compassion
may be infinite but our capacity to help
people is not
but
this is why the new plan for immigration
and its legislative vehicle the
nationality and borders bill are so
vital and once again i urge honourable
members but also members in the other
place to follow this elected house and
back in the book
at the heart of this government's
approach is a simple principle mr
speaker fairness
access to the uk's asylum system should
be based
access to the uk's asylum system should
be based on need not on the ability to
pay people smugglers
[Applause]
mr speaker more than 80 million people
around the world are displaced others
are on the move because they want a
better life there is a global migration
crisis that demands innovative and
international solutions and this
government is taking firm action
when i published the new plan for
immigration back in march last year we
set out three very clear objectives
to increase the fairness and efficacy of
our system so that we can better protect
and support those in genuine need of
asylum
to deter
illegal and dangerous routes of entry to
the uk thereby breaking the business
model of criminal smuggling networks and
protecting the lives of those they
endanger and mr speaker to remove more
easily from the uk
those with no right to be here
the ministry of defense has taken
command of small boat operations in the
channel every small boat incident will
be investigated to determine who piloted
the boat and could therefore be liable
for prosecution
these reforms are a truly
cross-government effort including the
home office the mod the crown
prosecution service border force and the
ministry of justice
a nationwide dispersal system will be
introduced so that asylum pressures more
equally spread across local authorities
currently 53 of local authorities in
england scotland and wales do not
accommodate asylum seekers under the
dispersal system
it is simply unfair that a national
burden should be felt disproportionately
by certain areas of the country
for the first time mr speaker the
government is building asylum reception
centers to end the practice of housing
asylum seekers in expensive hotels
a new reception center in lincoln upon
ooze in north yorkshire will open
shortly
far from being outlandish as some of the
opposition have commented asylum
reception centers are already
operational in safe eu countries such as
greece mr speaker and mr speaker they're
funded by the eu
and just last week i signed a new world
leading migration and economic
development partnership with rwanda
under this partnership
those who travel to the uk by illegal
and dangerous routes including buy small
boats across the channel may be
relocated to rwanda where they will have
their asylum claims considered
those in need of pros of protection will
be given up to five years of support
including education and employment
training help with integration
accommodation healthcare so that they
can thrive there mr speaker
the uk is supporting this investment in
rwanda over five years boosting the
rwandan economy and increasing the
opportunities of people living there
further cementing the trading and
diplomatic relationship between our
countries
mr speaker this is a bespoke
international agreement reached last
week with rwanda
i came to parliament as soon as was
reasonably practical following the
conclusion of that agreement this
agreement is comparable with all our
domestic and international legal
obligations
[Applause]
rwanda is a state party to the 1951
united nations refugee convention and
the seven core united nations human
rights convention and has a strong
system for refugee resettlement
the united nations has used rwanda for
several years to relocate refugees mr
speaker
and of course mr speaker it was the
european union who first funded this
this agreement deals a major blow to the
people smugglers the eve and their evil
trade in human cargo
everyone who is considered for
relocation will be screened and
interviewed including an age assessment
and have access to legal services
mr speaker in relation to accounting
officer advice contrary to reports in
the newspapers the permanent secretary
did not oppose this agreement nor assert
that it is poor value for money rather
he stated in his role as accounting
officer that the policy is regular
proper and feasible but there is not
currently sufficient evidence to
demonstrate value for money it is a job
of ministers to take decisions mr
speaker and it's a job of ministers mr
speaker more often than not to take
tough decisions in the interests of our
country
existing approaches mr speaker have
failed and there is no one single
solution to tackle these problems
something that i think the benches
opposites may have encountered in the
past as well
change is needed because people are
dying attempting to come to the uk
on illegal and dangerous rules this
partnership is a type of international
cooperation needed to make the global
immigration system fairer keep people
safe and give them opportunities to
flourish this will help break the people
smugglers business model and prevent the
loss of life while ensuring protection
for those who are generally genuinely
vulnerable
this government is delivering the first
comprehensive overhaul of the asylum
system and this type of illegal
migration in decades
at the heart of this approach mr speaker
is fairness access to the uk's asylum
system must be based on need not the
ability to pay people smugglers
and the demands on the current system
the cost of british taxpayers and the
scandalous abuses are increasing the
british public have rightly had enough
our new plan for immigration will
improve and support those directly
fleeing oppression persecution and
tyranny through safe and legal rules it
will deter illegal and dangerous routes
of entry to the uk make it easier to
remove those with no right to be in the
uk and mr speaker provide a common sense
approach to controlling immigration both
legal and illegal i commend the
statement to the house